[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
taking a look at one of the most beloved
innocent and selfless characters of the
entire series
dobby more specifically we're going to
be discussing dobby's death
and how its portrayal differed from book
to film
dobby the big hearted house elf first
makes his way into our lives
in the chamber of secrets when he enters
the home of number four privet drive
at one of the most inopportune times you
see
the day dobby decided to visit harry
potter at the dursey residence
happened to be the same day that vernon
dursley harry's terrible uncle
had a very important business dinner
with clients the chamber of secrets was
the first example of dobby
exhibiting extreme heroism as he tries
desperately to prevent harry from
returning to hogwarts
hoping to save his life the actions he
took in visiting harry
were technically in defiance of his
current masters harry potter must
not go back to hogwarts school of
witchcraft and wizardry this year
dobby who served at the malfoys knew of
the plan to reopen
the chamber of secrets during harry
potter's second year
at hogwarts for this reason he began to
intercept harry's mail
when harry finds out what dobby had been
doing he was furious
but dobby's actions were entirely
selfless he just wanted harry to be safe
when harry refuses dobby's request
he ends up dumping aunt petunia's
pudding all over the house guests
as i mentioned this was just the first
example of dobby
acting selflessly to protect harry
dobby's big-hearted nature
quickly becomes apparent to the reader
earning a special place in our hearts
unfortunately however dobby eventually
became another one of the casualties
suffered in the wizarding war
sacrificing himself to protect harry and
his friends
helping them to escape from malfoy manor
in this video
i want to discuss dobby's death and how
it varied from book to film
here's the thing dobby though crucial to
the story
is considerably less developed in the
film than in the books
this is ultimately one of the reasons
that his death wasn't as impactful as it
should have been
in the film dobby was barely anything
more than a malfoy's former house elf
who warned harry about the chamber of
secrets and later appearing once again
to save them from the death eaters the
dobby of the books was just
so much more than that which is one of
the reasons why his death
was so heartbreaking dobby's whole story
was glossed over
and his death simply didn't have the
emphasis that it should have
instead of an astounding selfless act of
heroism
dobby's death served as more of a
transition point
between the two deathly hallows movies
it just didn't have the impact
that it deserved as the focus wasn't
placed on him
but more so the trio and the
continuation of the plot
the books bear a very different
representation starting with the sheer
heroism
exhibited by dobby by returning to the
home of his old masters
dobby's enormous tennis ball-shaped eyes
were wide
he was trembling from his feet to the
tips of his ears he was back in the home
of his old masters
and it was clear that he was petrified
returning to the malfoy manor requires
just as much courage as any worthy
gryffindor and it served as a testament
to just how far dobby would go to help
harry
but here's the thing not only did dobby
have to return to the manor
he ended up having to defy his old
masters even going as far as to try to
intentionally
harm them you see it was dobby that
dropped the chandelier
that hung above bellatrix at the last
word there was a peculiar grinding noise
from above
all of them looked upward in time to see
the crystal chandelier tremble
then with the creek and an ominous
tingling it began to fall
bellatrix was directly beneath it
dropping hermione
she threw herself aside with a scream
the chandelier crashed to the floor
in an explosion of crystal and chains as
narcissa dragged draco out of the way of
further harm
bellatrix sprang to her feet her hair
flying as she brandished the silver
knife
but narcissa had directed her wand at
the doorway
dobby she screamed and even bellatrix
froze
you you dropped the chandelier the tiny
elf trotted into the room
his shaking finger pointing at his old
mistress you must not
hurt harry potter he squeaked but dobby
didn't stop at dropping the chandelier
he also stripped them of their ones kill
him
shrieked bellatrix but there was another
loud crack
and narcissus wand two flew into the air
and landed on the other side of the room
you dirty little monkey bald bellatrix
how dare you take a witch's wand
how dare you defy your masters dobby has
no master squealed the elf dobby is a
free elf
and dobby has come to save harry potter
and his friends
though dobby was filled with more fear
than he ever could have imagined
he still stood his ground in the face of
his former masters
not only was this his opportunity to
save his friends but it was a chance for
him to declare his independence
in front of the people that enslaved him
for so many years
it was heroism exhibited in its purest
noblest form
tragically however standing up to the
people that mistreated him for so many
years
ended up being one of the last things
dobby ever did
for his death was near hoisting the
groaning goblin
who still clung to the sword over one
shoulder harry seized dobby's hand and
spun
on the spot to disappearate as he turned
into darkness
he caught one last view of the drawing
room of the pale frozen figures of
narcissa
and draco of the streak of red that was
ron's hair
and a blue of flying silver as
bellatrix's knife
flew across the room at the place where
he was vanishing
and what happened next was truly
heartbreaking as harry notices that
though they were able to operate out of
malfoy manor the knife that bellatrix
had thrown
operated with them striking dobby
dobby the elf swayed slightly stars
reflected in his wide
shining eyes together he and harry
looked down at the silver hilt of the
knife protruding from the elf's heaving
chest
dobby no help harry bellowed toward the
cottage
toward the people moving there help he
did not know or care whether they were
wizards or muggles
friends or foes all he cared about was
that a dark stain
was spreading across dobby's front and
that he had stretched out his own arms
to harry
the look of supplication harry caught
him and laid him sideways on the cool
grass
dobby no don't die don't die
the elf's eyes found him and his lips
trembled with the effort
to form words harry potter
and then with a little shudder the elf
became
quite still and his eyes were nothing
more than great
glassy orbs sprinkled with light from
the stars
they could not see the harry potter
series certainly doesn't shy away from
characters dying
but i will say this dobby's death was
one of the most significant
the actions he took to save harry and
his friends exhibited a level of bravery
shown
by almost no other character in this
series and i think that it's a shame
that
the films failed to emphasize this it
was a disservice to his character
as dobby made the ultimate sacrifice to
make sure that his friends were safe
if there's one thing we can take away
from dobby's death book or film
it's that heroes come in all shapes and
sizes dobby
the tiny formerly enslaved house elf
divide
some of the most powerful death eaters
in a wizarding world saving the lives of
his friends
and helping to secure the future of the
wizarding world
rest in peace dobby and that's it for
this video
what do you guys think did you notice
that dobby's death was
rather understated in the film were
there any other deaths that didn't get
the attention
they deserved let me know in the comment
section below
until next time dobby has come to
protect
even if he does have to shut his ears in
the oven door
[Music]
you